vamos a adentrarnos en el mundo de la
mitocondria muy bien y la mitocondria es
probablemente mi organelos favorito de
la célula así que hagamos un breve de un
breve repaso de qué son las mitocondrias
para poder ahondar un poco más en su
estructura así que vamos a pensar por
ahora en una célula eucariontes e
inmediatamente tú podrás decir bueno se
supone que las células eucariontes
tienen un núcleo que están delimitados
por una membrana verdad entonces aquí
tenemos este núcleo y la membrana
nuclear verdad y ahora vamos a colocar
digamos el adn dentro de nuestro núcleo
verdad ahí tenemos el adn dentro del
núcleo y entonces también dirás bueno se
supone que hay otro tipo de órgano los
que también están delimitados por
membranas en las células eucariontes
verdad y uno de esos organelos
delimitados por membranas que es muy
importante para la célula es
la mitocondria muy bien entonces vamos a
pintar aquí un par de mitocondrias aquí
tenemos una primera mitocondria y ahora
en más adelante ya que hablemos sobre la
estructura de la mitocondria voy a decir
porque estamos poniendo estas estas
especies de líneas dentro de ellas para
que quede claro estas son las
mitocondrias y quizás lo hayas visto en
otro vídeo de lacan academy pero a las
mitocondrias se les considera fábricas
de atp que la mitocondria se le
considera como la fábrica de atp de atp
de la célula verdad y de hecho lo
mencionamos en digamos repetidas
ocasiones quizás en vídeos de
respiración celular o quizás en vídeos
de atp pero hemos dicho que justamente
el atp es la moneda energética de las
células
digamos que que cuando pierde uno uno de
los fosfatos verdad porque atp es
adenosín trifosfato cuando cuando pierde
uno de esos fosfatos entonces el late
y libera energía y es la energía que se
usa en el cuerpo para hacer distintas
actividades por ejemplo moverse puede
ser una de ellas y de hecho las
mitocondrias son muy importantes para la
energía celular verdad por eso es que
por ejemplo hay muchas más mitocondrias
en células musculares verdad porque
utilizan mucha energía ok ahora hablemos
un poco sobre el fascinante pasado de
las mitocondrias porque por ejemplo la
teoría celular nos dice que la célula es
la unidad más básica de la vida verdad
pero la teoría prevalente dice que las
mitocondrias entraron a la célula pues
los ancestros de las mitocondrias eran
microorganismos independientes así que
en algún momento de la historia verdad
la historia evolutiva de la vida en la
tierra digamos los ancestros de la
mitocondria eran quizás organismos
independientes verdad que digamos fueron
ingeridos por los ancestros de nuestras
células verdad y en vez de ser digerir
parece que si estos seres verdad los los
ancestros de la mitocondria si esos
seres se quedaban por ahí deambulando
digamos dentro de la célula era más
probable que sobreviviera en verdad
quizás porque porque ayudaban a procesar
digámoslo la glucosa o ayudaban a
generar más energía verdad así las
células pudieron vivir en simbiosis con
los ancestros de la mitocondria
sobrevivieron y por el proceso de la
selección natural ahora asociamos a las
células eucariontes con el hecho de que
poseen mitocondrias muy bien así que
esta idea de un organismo viviendo
dentro de otro individuo en simbiosis el
hecho de que puedan vivir así aún en un
nivel celular me parece increíble ahora
hablemos del presente y de cómo es la
estructura actual de la mitocondria así
que para estudiar la estructura de la
mitocondria vamos a dibujar una especie
de corte transversal ahí tenemos
si cortamos por la mitad la mitocondria
nuestro nuestro corte de verdad aquí
tenemos el corte transversal de nuestra
mitocondria verdad y esto que tenemos
dibujado en verde es la membrana externa
que ya está es la membrana externa
membrana externa y si recordamos las
características que tienen las membranas
en las células verdad podríamos hacer un
acercamiento de nuestra membrana vamos a
hacer un acercamiento como lo hemos
estado haciendo siempre verdad y ésta
está formada por una bicapa de
fosfolípidos entonces aquí tenemos
nuestra bicapa de fosfolípidos tenemos
cabezas hidrofílicas que apuntan hacia
el exterior verdad o digamos hacia
afuera mientras que las colas
hidrofóbicas apuntan en esta dirección
verdad entonces aquí tenemos una
representación de nuestra bicapa de
fosfolípidos que por digamos es lo que
conforma nuestra membrana externa verdad
y por supuesto también hay otro tipo de
cosas digamos encajadas en las membranas
por ejemplo hay proteínas y enzimas que
regulan lo que hay dentro y fuera de la
mitocondria así que
vamos recordemos que la célula en
realidad es sumamente compleja y puede
tener muchas otras digamos sus
estructuras dentro de la membrana pero
bueno una de estas proteínas que están
en la membrana externa es la purina muy
bien entonces déjenme hacer un dibujo
más o menos de cómo se ve más o menos
tenemos algo así son son especies
digamos de agujeros que están en nuestra
membrana externa muy bien y estos de
estas proteínas se llaman purinas
purinas estas son purinas y son como es
como una especie de agujeros que no
permiten el paso de moléculas grandes
solo de moléculas chicas como azúcares o
iones ok y pasan estos iones pueden
pasar de forma pasiva a través de las
purinas verdad esto permite que las
concentraciones de estos iones o de
azúcares sean similares tanto dentro de
la membrana externa como fuera de ella
verdad y por supuesto no es la única
membrana con la que contamos en la
mitocondria también tenemos una membrana
interna que estoy tratando de dibujar
por aquí que más o menos este es el
dibujo de la membrana interna de la
mitocondria aunque esta es la membrana
interna miembro
interna y digamos esta membrana interna
tiene pliegues verdad que aumentan el
área de superficie verdad y esto es muy
importante pues es ahí en digamos sobre
la superficie de la membrana interna
verdad donde se lleva a cabo la cadena
de transporte de electrones verdad así
que si aumentamos la superficie es
verdad el área de superficie podemos
tener más de este proceso verdad ahora
bien estos pliegues que tenemos aquí
tienen un nombre particular y se les
conoce como crestas muy bien estas son
crestas de la membrana interna y
nuevamente la membrana interna también
está compuesta por una bicapa de
fosfolípidos ahora bien entre ambas
membranas verdad tenemos un espacio aquí
entre ambas membranas y justamente a
este espacio le vamos a conocer como el
espacio inter membranoso
ínter membranoso
no es un nombre bastante original verdad
es bastante simple verdad este es el
espacio intervendrán oso y debido a las
purinas verdad a la presencia de las
purinas vamos a tener que la
concentración de moléculas pequeñas en
el espacio intervendrán oso y el citó
sol verdad lo que está fuera de la
mitocondria en la célula verdad es es
más o menos parecida no es es más o
menos igual verdad pero la membrana
interna no tiene purinas verdad esta
membrana interna no tiene purinas y
puede haber concentraciones distintas y
eso de hecho es fundamental para la
cadena de transporte de electrones
verdad ésta se combina con un gradiente
de hidrógeno entre ambos lados verdad lo
que hay dentro de la membrana interna y
lo que hay fuera verdad y este gradiente
baja por una proteína llamada atp sin
tasa que de hecho ayuda a sintetizar atp
verdad pero bueno hablaremos de esto más
adelante o quizás en otro vídeo ahora
bien dentro de la membrana interna
verdad hablemos de lo que hay dentro de
la membrana
tenemos este espacio dentro de la
membrana ya ésta le conocemos a este
espacio digamos como matriz verdad y de
hecho tiene este nombre recibe el nombre
de matriz porque tiene una concentración
alta de proteínas verdad esto de aquí le
llamamos matriz tiene una alta
concentración de proteínas y además es
más viscoso que el cito sol muy bien así
que cuando hablamos por ejemplo de la
respiración celular verdad
hablamos de una fase muy importante que
es la glucólisis y de hecho la
glucólisis se lleva a cabo en el sito
sol verdad aquí es en donde se lleva a
cabo la glucólisis
se lleva a cabo la glucólisis ahora bien
otra de las fases importantes en la
respiración celular es el ciclo del
ácido cítrico que también conocemos como
el ciclo de krebs
de hecho el ciclo de krebs ahora no
ocurre en el en el sito sol sino ocurre
en la matriz ocurre en la matriz
mitocondrial verdad aquí es en donde
ocurre el ciclo de krebs también
hablamos de la cadena de transporte de
electrones verdad que es la responsable
de la producción de atp y esto se lleva
a cabo gracias a unas proteínas que se
encuentran en las crestas de la membrana
interna verdad aquí tenemos esas
proteínas y es en donde se lleva a cabo
la producción de atp es por la cadena de
transporte de electrones ahora bien
probablemente una de las características
más interesantes que tiene digamos la
mitocondria es que son descendientes de
otras formas de vida y que eran
independientes de la célula verdad y
como tal entonces deberían tener
información genética
así es de hecho tienen adn mitocondrial
que se encuentra en lazos aquí podríamos
pensar en lazos que se encuentran en la
matriz mitocondrial verdad se encuentran
en forma de lazos y de hecho tenemos
muchas copias de este adn así que aquí
lo que obtengo lo que encontramos es el
adn mitocondrial mito con dryad verdad y
tenemos muchas copias están digamos
distribuidas como en lazos verdad y
justo de hecho esto se parece mucho al
adn bacteriano y por eso creemos que en
digamos hace tiempo eran individuos
independientes y que eran muy parecidos
a las bacterias muy bien entonces tú
tienes tu propio adn verdad y ese adn se
encuentra en el núcleo de todas tus
células pero además tienes mitocondrias
que tienen adn y verdad y tienen su
propio adn y este adn de las
mitocondrias proviene esencialmente de
tu madre
entonces vamos a esbozar porque esto es
así digamos aquí tenemos un óvulo más o
menos esta es la ya la idea de un óvulo
aquí tenemos un núcleo y este óvulo está
lleno de muchas mitocondrias verdad y
por supuesto también los espermatozoides
tendrán digamos aquí tenemos un
espermatozoide también tendrán sus
mitocondrias y de hecho es útil verdad
para promover el movimiento y poder
llegar a fecundar el óvulo verdad
entonces una vez que entra el
espermatozoide dentro del óvulo
todas esas mitocondrias son digeridas
verdad además bueno pues los óvulos
tienen más más mitocondrias que los
espermatozoides así que esencialmente el
adn mitocondrial proviene de tu madre
una vez que ya está fecundado el óvulo
verdad y esto es bastante útil verdad
esto es muy útil porque cuando la gente
habla de rastrear digamos a la madre
común en realidad están están hablando
de que están buscando en el a
mitocondrial y esto es un tema sumamente
fascinante ahora esto que presente es un
modelo digamos que podría venir en algún
libro de texto porque cuando vemos una
micrografía que de hecho voy a
mostrarles aquí abajo cuando vemos una
micrografía que es lo que tenemos del
lado izquierdo vemos este tipo de
pliegues verdad que tenemos aquí en la
mitocondria verdad y parece que eso
respalda nuestro modelo pero pero cuando
usamos técnicas de visualización mucho
más complicadas y sofisticadas resulta
que no sólo tenemos digamos estos
pliegues verdad que son las crestas
verdad sino que además tenemos unos
túneles que conectan digamos el espacio
dentro de las crestas con el espacio
internet planos o verdad y de hecho me
gustan este tipo de cosas porque digamos
en los libros de textos se muestran las
mitocondrias como teníamos en este
modelo de aquí arriba verdad tenemos las
mitocondrias y en los libros de texto no
se ve qué
que en la realidad aún no entendemos del
todo cómo funcionan y cómo están
estructuradas verdad cuando vemos esta
imagen de las crestas verdad cuando
cuando tenemos esta imagen de aquí en
realidad ya no es un modelo aceptado
para la estructura de la mitocondria más
bien es algo como lo que tenemos aquí
abajo verdad es algo como esto en donde
tenemos y de hecho podemos intentar
hacer un dibujo nosotros tenemos digamos
aquí nuestra membrana externa tenemos
nuestra membrana interna y hay como una
especie de túneles que conectan a las
crestas verdad que conectan a las
crestas con el espacio intervendrán oso
verdad así que espero que aprecies que
cuando uno toma digamos un libro de
texto en biología podríamos pensar que
las cosas ya fueron descubiertas y ya no
hay nada más que hacer pero en realidad
la gente aún sigue investigando cómo
están estructuradas cómo está
estructurado este orgánulo cómo es que
funciona y cómo
que hace las cosas que tiene que hacer